hi I'm Erik Bosse and as we look ahead
to have interest in game we're still
left with a mystery of what exactly
happened a half of all sentient life at
the end of infinity war like yeah we saw
him disintegrate into dandruff but like
obviously it ain't final because no
Spider Man an exterior coming back and
you know we're all human being so
struggling to accept finality and
creating crazy alternative explanations
is in our DNA
well then recently we were validated
because the directors of in-game and
infinity war the Russos I've been doing
interviews with a digital effects team
to promote infinity warfare Awards
consideration and they revealed some
major details about how exactly the
dusting worked and they might have clued
us in into how all this can be fixed an
endgame I'm gonna break this new stuff
down and spoiler warning the guys are
gonna rap okay so the Russos and the VFX
team were asked by Collider about the
moment of Thanos to snap and how the
dusting was designed and they revealed
that originally the dusting was going to
look way different they pointed out how
each time Thanos used the Infinity
stones throughout the movie the move is
color-coded like when he uses the blue
space stone the person or thing affected
glows blue or when he uses a purple
power stone the energy blast is purple
so for the snap all six stones are of
course activated so they initially
wanted each dusted individual to have a
color-coded glow as well the idea that
was you know that there was the dust and
there was kind of a night light interior
light like the soul was there and it's
interesting so let's picture that in
addition to the character fading in a
dust and inner light showing their soul
or essence was going to be there as well
this actually reflects some imagery that
we saw in concept art for the film
depicting Thanos blasting the heroes
souls from their bodies artists went on
to say that they decided to change this
because this glowing soul thing was
distracting from the actors performances
which actually told them a lot more
about the characters in these moments
he's singled out Tom Holland who
portrayed Peter Parker's death as a slow
gradual bleed out his spidey sense
allowed him to detect deaths approach so
he tried to escape it the same way that
the kid has escaped every other threat
that he is sensed and the way he dusts
away reflects that struggle gradually
working up his body until he whispers
his final apology to Tony Stark
by comparison scarlet witch's death that
we saw is more of a surrender in a way
she has already died
or the snap when Thanos killed vision so
notice how Elizabeth Olsen throws her
head back and gives in to the dust as if
to say just take me away from this pain
they also mentioned Bucky the first
character we saw fade away he holds off
just long enough to ask Steve and then
he bursts into dust when he collapses
and hits the ground if past interviews
the VFX guys have pointed out how the
Guardians dusting quill Drax and mantis
on Titan it's more like a sucker punch
because they're genuinely caught by
surprise but then compare that to dr.
Strange's final moment his dust looks a
lot like scarlet witch's a surrender he
knows this is coming he probably saw it
in his glimpse of the future any times
his surrender only long enough to
explain to Stark there was no other way
as if to say trust me this setback was
necessary for us to beat Thanos the
directors actors and visual effects
artists were able to tell a lot of story
with each of these moments especially
when you consider that the script for
this moment reportedly only described it
with two words they disappear and the
story they ended up telling was rooted
in the choices made by the actors and
characters themselves the color coded
glow idea would have corresponded neatly
to the other times Thanos used a stone
but now the gray monochromatic dust
keeps our focus on the actors faces the
dust itself is the least visually
distracting color and texture like
notice how it immediately blends in with
the surroundings not even a pile left
behind actually recently Falcon actor
Anthony Mackie described his experience
acting out his dustin scene and looking
back the direction given him by the
Russos now takes on an interesting light
like we were on set and I'm laying down
in the mud and it's cold and the
director goes yeah the Russo brothers
are like you're you're you're
disintegrating to think about your
leaving Earth what would you say and I'm
like cap does yeah definitely worth
noting at the Russos told Mackie that
Falcon was leaving Earth it's a very
spiritual way to describe this moment
like rather than the fear of finality
which was the emotional base for Peter
Parker's final moments they wanted the
Falcon it seemed like he was departing
this earthly realm and transporting to a
different place in the cosmos like maybe
they simply wanted Mackie to think about
the traditional view of heaven or the
afterlife but to me this
does that go the description of the VFX
team this idea of an inner soul that the
hero's dust into so if all the dusted
souls actually went somewhere where do
they go well they could be contained in
the soul stone like Gomorrah was in a
kind of suspended state a spiritual
limbo for ghosts or maybe since they
said each dust was going to be color
coded initially maybe each of the dusted
could be trapped inside a different
stone or if we you know open our brains
to more cosmic possibilities leaving
earth could bring them to another
dimension entirely like they could be in
Hell the grim afterlife dimension that
Thor's sister hello was banished to or
they could be somewhere in the quantum
realm there is that theory we discussed
that the orange quantum healing
particles could be subatomic fragments
of people's souls no no no that's true
but we do know that a big part of
Avengers in game will be quantum related
we've seen some toy leaks with the
Avengers wearing new gray armor that
looked a lot like Hank PIMs quantum suit
from ant-man the wasp these are being
called quantum Armour and remember a
while ago Tom Hollands said in an
interview that a lot of Benedict
Cumberbatch's dialogue had the words
quantum realm in it he lines though he
has to talk about so much quantum realm
stuff just so I just have to talk about
yeah man that's awesome this is cool
mines easy thanks you gotta love that
reaction from Cumberbatch so stuff it's
just stuff don't specify what kind of
stuff it's just stuff stomach it gotta
reminds me of that similar moment with
Don Cheadle and Mark Ruffalo and Ruffalo
spoiled the end of infinity war in
nearly 10 months before the movie came
out wait till you see this next one hark
everybody talks dude do not everybody
know that can we rewind that part yeah
oh yeah the fact that dr. strange never
said the phrase quantum realm once an
infinity war leads me to think that he's
gonna have some real complicated
technical tongue-twisters to explain to
the other adventures in endgame I think
the quantum realm is gonna play a major
role in his mysterious plan which
initially seemed like a surrender to
dust but is actually a long game an end
game to reversing the mad Titan snap
where do you think these dusted Avengers
souls went comment down below with your
thoughts and follow me on twitter and
instagram at a vas and subscribe to new
rockstars and if you happen to live in
the LA area come check out my monthly
comedy show darkest timeline comedy
Friday March 1st at the Acme Theatre in
North Hollywood thanks for watching and
I just realized that when I die I'm
gonna come here on YouTube where I'll
live on or not guess this is my legacy
[Music]